growing up on a dairy farm you learn why
they had five kids Labor's a lot cheaper
that way and so we spent the summers
working out in the and the grape
vineyards you really learned the value
of hard work growing up on a farm learn
the value of community graduated from
the same public school that my dad and
my grandfather and my brothers graduated
from I was a page in the US House of
Representatives my junior year of high
school so here you have a little farm
boy from Southwest Michigan that never
spent much time off the farm going off
to Washington DC working on the floor of
the house going to school of the Library
of Congress really learned a lot in
terms of how to be involved in in
politics and really make make a
difference after high school I played a
lot of different in schools but Hill's I
just felt the most at home with that
they want to teach how to learn instead
of what to learn I thought that was very
important so after I graduated manage to
campaign for a person running for the
state Senate provided me a lot of
knowledge and understanding of
fundraising and dealing with the media
and and approving mail pieces and TV and
all the stuff from the political side
that's needed to make the policy work in
February of 2010 I decided to come back
home and decide it was time for me to
step up I thought I could make a
difference that what was happening up in
Lansing wasn't working I quit my job I
didn't have a paycheck for ten months
and I just went out there knocking doors
throughout the entire district in the
fall I was able to win by 30 points and
so there was a stamp and we came in that
fall with the Republican majority in the
House Republican majority in the Senate
a Republican governor and we rolled up
our sleeves and we got to work for the
citizens of Michigan I served by six
years three two-year terms that's the
maximum can serve in the house governor
Snyder called me up and asked me if I
wanted to work for the administration
offered me the role of lottery
commissioner and drew the single person
in charge of the entire state lottery
Bureau 3.1 billion dollar sales
organization
oh I'm very blessed and proud to to ever
receive this and I hope I can live up to
the standards that Hillsdale a set
[Music]